starting to struggle a little bit up
here my sweat stashes pop it off oh I
felt like I should have just eaten the
chip it would help with the hotness what
hello I'm Merle I'm a chef for good full
I love love love love love love love hot
sauce my name is Teddy and I'm a hot
sauce guru I love my hot sauce I put
that on everything so today I'm gonna be
going toe-to-toe with an amateur hot
sauce lover that means we're gonna try
to figure out which hot sauce is which
while blindfolded so my favorite hot
sauce is probably sriracha I'm not like
super picky but I can appreciate a good
hot sauce 1 times 1 in front me Tapatio
hands down and there's no salsa around I
always reach out for some Tapatio i
saute a lot of things so anything I'm
sauteing whether it's just like
vegetables tofu any kind of protein I
just always I like to have a nice kick
to it so I toss hot sauce on honestly
everything put on chips ramen tacos with
mac and cheese baked beans rice I can
put it on cereal on cereal maybe I
should put on syrup time to try these
hot sauces I'm feeling good let's get
into this first hot sauce okay so this
is hot sauce number one
I heard the bottle being shaken sounded
like it was a loser based hot sauce you
always want to smell it
oh really smell the vinegar it's all
about texture it's all about intensity
let's see oh yeah
oh it's definitely hot sauce that would
pair well with like wings I first
thought I was sriracha but there's no
wakes it's too loose I'm in between
Tabasco and Franks
I'm just gonna stick with Franks on this
one yeah it's making me think of like
baseball games because it's making me
think of baseball games and because I
thought it was Franks and I feel like
it's Franks I'm gonna say Franks I'm
gonna call it a day so this next one
let's see there we go again
yeah smell it whoa yeah this is like a
unique smell off the bat oh yeah there's
might a little bit more of a bite to it
I don't normally go
you know like tongue first hit hot sauce
I'm usually enjoying it with something
else
strong vinegary and it tastes the first
okay yeah this one makes me feel like a
late-night drunken bad decision I'm
gonna say this one's Tabasco I think I
had it up I'm Nestle Tabasco on this one
Oh baby okay so the last one is still
kind of holding on to my tongue for dear
life right now which I feel like might
make it harder to taste these next ones
sauce number three hold it
ooh this one's got little more on cumin
see now it's starting to all kind of
blend in with each other they're all
kind of smelling pretty similar this
one's sweeter okay that one didn't give
a hard enough kick as the others pretty
like Mao oh yeah flavorful okay this
one's nicer to me
comes around though now it's starting to
to give me a little feedback um
so something you probably pour over like
some nice soup you know some nice
chicken ramen or chicken noodle soup no
this one makes me think of margaritas
I'm gonna go with Cholula on this one
she's really poured a lot in there it's
pulled up
I just doesn't feel like sweet baby rave
this one tastes like a traditional hot
sauce I'm gonna say to Loula number four
this has a unique smell
sriracha just has that a garlic thicker
texture to to top sauce so let's see
I mean we all know what's wrong is good
for slap it on chow mein I would prefer
it on noodles but honestly any type of
chicken Oh garlic I think it has a
unique texture and a unique smell that
one kind of give it away I think it is
okay that's alright I think it's
sriracha deference watcher if I get
sriracha wrong I'm gonna be embarrassed
but but I'm also gonna blame it on the
fact that my taste buds are gone the
blend of hot sauce is now is starting to
like throw my taste buds out of whack
I'm noticing the intricacy is there
something about being blindfolded it
really makes you be mindful about what
you're putting in your mouth even hot
but I feel pretty confident think I'm
kind of getting them right on the nose
like I'm killing it I'm feeling pretty
good right now I think partially it's
the hot sauce it's really way can fire
me up but also I'm feeling good alright
this is the last one nope I do not like
that oh I like this this is really good
I can pour this over chips I think that
one's the sweet baby Ray's one because
I've never had I feel like this is the
one that I don't really have as often
sweet Bay Rays and Frank's Red Hot are
the ones that I'm having trouble with
this one had a unique taste that I
haven't really had I'm gonna go with
sweet memories on this one you know what
I feel pretty darn confident I want to
say I got at least three out of the five
just because I'm really confused between
Franks and sweet baby Ray's my eyes are
flowing my nose is flowing my tongue is
swollen I'm ready to take this frickin
blindfold off I think I did really well
I think I knocked it out of the park
another chef works with all kinds of
agreed ease of the time that include hot
sauce so I mean I'm sure they know their
sauce as well but I think as a hot sauce
guru I have this in the bag
oh I did pretty well I just messed up
these two damn okay all right wow I'm
actually so happy with that oh okay see
ya I was a little confused on that one
they said Frank's Tabasco just has that
unique smell you know so these are
pretty known to be used with like
buffalo wings and anything you want to
spice anything up for a buffalo flavor
obviously Sofie it was a 50-50 toss-up
at that point I mean yesterday I wish I
got all of them right of course I'm just
kind of proud of myself like to tie up
with the chef so listen guys left in
life you can't get all of them right all
the time and honestly after tasting like
four of them my tastebuds were gone
anyway like to go neck to neck with the
chef that's pretty impressive I love a
good spice I like a good kick and I
think it's really cool to taste the
intricacies of each individual one I
don't know I think it's still a win even
if it's a win for both of us
[Music]